une deuxième vague dévastatrice qui a
entraîné les gouverneurs de plusieurs
états brésiliens à passer à la phase
violette la plus stricte du confinement
à sao paulo pour la première fois un
couvre-feu a été instauré de 20h à 5h du
matin et les week-ends mais cette mesure
est plus ou moins respecté
bonsoir nous avons reçu une réclamation
il paraît que vous organisez une grosse
fête ici ce soir on aimerait savoir ce
qu'il se passe ces personnes là ne croit
ni au virus en mis à l'abandon d'animaux
pandémie
alors qu'on voit bien que la pandémie
n'est pas finie au contraire elle est de
plus en plus forte
de l'autre côté de la bulle l'ambiance
n'est pas à la fête au brésil 38
millions de personnes sont des
travailleurs informels
depuis l'arrivée du coronavirus 40%
d'entre eux auraient perdu tous leurs
revenus alors dans les favelas ce les
dons alimentaires se multiplient pour
survivre cap sur la périphérie sud de
sao paulo où l'association centrale
unique des favelas ce géré par marcelo
cavagna distribuer nourriture et
produits hygiéniques aux plus démunis
grâce à ce type d'association plus d'un
million de familles ont pu bénéficier de
cette aide
on distribue du gel hydroalcoolique des
masques des gâteaux des produits
d'entretien un panier alimentaire des
pâtes des sardines en boîte de la farine
[Musique]
la vie des gens ici a toujours été
difficile
la pandémie n'a fait qu'empirer la
situation
le gouvernement ayant quasiment stoppé
son programme de subventions sociales
mises en place durant la crise
de nombreuses familles ont vu leur
situation s'aggraver c'est le cas de
maria aparecida vendeuse autonome
actuellement chômage qui va tous les
jours chercher des dons de nourriture
pour survire et nourrir ses deux enfants
au début j'ai touché 100 dollars après
seulement 50
et là je ne reçois plus rien les
factures sont en retard cela fait plus
d'une semaine qu'on n'a pas mangé de la
viande
je vis des dons de fruits de produits
basiques ça devient de plus en plus
difficile de survivre dans les hôpitaux
le manque de respect des mesures
sanitaires est largement ressentie les
services de plusieurs grandes villes
brésiliennes sont saturés avec un taux
d'occupation qui dépasse 100 % et les
listes d'attentes en soins intensifs ne
désemplissent pas à são paulo l'hôpital
de brazil en dia celui qui compte le
plus de lits en unité de soins intensifs
de la ville est un des seuls à avoir
encore quelques places
le médecin marcelo signorelli tire la
sonnette d'alarmé à l'intérieur des
hôpitaux nous vivons des moments très
forts très lourd
il faut que les gens fassent attention
qu'ils restent chez eux qu'ils portent
le masque qu'il mette du gel
hydroalcoolique pour qu'il ne soit pas
obligé de finir ici à l'hôpital
si le gouvernement se vante de la
vaccination de près de 10 millions de
personnes le nombre de morts est encore
très élevé
cette semaine le brésil a franchi son
record de décès quotidiens avec près de
2000 morts chaque jour
il maintient donc sa place de deuxième
pays le plus endeuillé au monde par le
cos vite 19